have you have you watched the movie The
Last Dance have you watched yeah I loved
it so a couple questions for you uh one
uh the moment with Isaiah and Jordan
okay and I see you as a guy that you
kind of you you you maybe you watch the
competition and everybody else can be
I've seen your shot your turnaround shot
you got a good game as well you're an
athlete you know you're a guy that kind
of follows uh along with what's going on
everywhere
the moment of Isaiah not shaking his
hand when they lost
and they walk off Bill and beer and
Michael's like you kidding me I lost you
last year humiliated I came and she'll
call your hands one by one by one and I
said they go in the championship I go in
the gym come back train we beat you you
don't want to even give me that respect
no problem
and Michael was a grudge guy yeah okay
and then Dream Team boom doesn't let him
get back on the team and well it was
never Michael it was never this on okay
well it was Michael let's just say and
then come to the Celebration that
happened last year a few months ago
where all the top 75 NBA players are
there there's there's this one scene
that's gone viral on Tick Tock and I
don't know if you know which I haven't
seen it now there's one scene that's
gone viral it's freaking hilarious yeah
where you see magic is there shaking
hands with Isaiah
and Michael's standing behind magic okay
and uh Magic's like yeah yeah all this
stuff all this stuff and then Isaiah
walks off and he said Michael comes and
he whispers something in Magic's ear and
this is within seconds after he talks to
Isaiah and they are both laughing so
hard yeah right now a couple trolls
added additional sound to say what would
have been said I'm gonna show you
afterwards it's unbelievably funny yeah
did you in your career
ever have an Isaiah Thomas
I could hold the grudge as good as any
of them out there actually I uh that
that was good aspects of of I would say
the motivation like you know I
it's it's very different like I didn't
have any friends on the other teams I
didn't you know and I think it's a
little different day and age yeah I
didn't I was X teammates I left well
yeah to a degree but I mean I was my
friends were the guys that were in the
battle with me so it's very different in
today's age which I actually think is a
little
uh
uh you've got to create
a lot of different emotion to to
heighten your sense of awareness and
focus like for me anger was good anger
was good because it was motivating the
more I could create an enemy the more I
want to go and kill those guys now I
knew I wasn't going to kill them
physically but man if I could just
what did they say you know and what did
they look like do they disrespect me at
all you know and did that also say
something
like those are little little little
things that can get me right in the
emotional frame of mind that when I run
on the field and I said let's go
it was really let's go kick some ass
that's what we were doing
so
there wasn't a lot of smiley faces with
me out there there wasn't a lot of
smiley faces with Michael Jordan there
weren't a lot of smiley faces with Kobe
Bryant there weren't a lot of smiley
faces with Tiger Woods
right tiger wasn't trying to be friends
with anybody tiger had no friends
Tiger's friends were guys that he knew
he could kick their butt those were
Tiger's friends
and they were very happy to have their
butts kicked by Tiger Wood be his friend
the tiger had him right where he wanted
them and I think for me like even when I
watched sports today and I see like
golf's a good example I see these guys
on the Range yeah they they're all
buddies and their caddies are friends
and I'm like that's not the Killer
Instinct that's just not I don't I don't
know how you can wanna crush the
competition because they are your
competition but then they're like have
dinner with them the next night now I
had a few friends like because maybe it
was a long period of time but I could
count on one hand the number of
maybe Peyton Manning and I and I love
Peyton maybe I've had dinner with him
twice
in 23 years and it's not because I don't
love them I really do twice in 20 years
probably three years and you know our
competition was always like
I looked up to him so much I admired
Peyton Manning like I I loved his game I
loved everything he did but
if if we wanted to get where we wanted
to go we had to get through them
so I had to create something different
in my mind he couldn't be my friend you
know when I see that with
a lot of the guys that you know Drew
Brees I love Drew he was incredible but
he wasn't my friend now he's my friend
because I'm not competing them against
anymore and I just think it's different
now because of social media the ability
to connect with everybody everyone's
friends now in sports all the time and
I'm like I don't get that
that's just not my thing so and it's not
that like I'm trying to be a jerk but in
my job it's different than my person you
know my
it's it's interesting like when I was a
quarterback I was just playing
quarterback yeah it was me the person
but it was it was me the quarterback
that was out there because I was doing a
job I wasn't the father I wasn't the dad
out there I wasn't you know the husband
out there I was the quarterback out
there on the field I was a quarterback
when I went to work nothing was going to
get in the way of that you know and then
when I stepped off the field great I'm
back to who I am I had to draw on a part
of me that was emotional yeah aggressive
angry decisive sick irrational
all those things and then when I came
back into life you know okay well like
calm down you know so
but I would say a lot of the guys that I
looked up to approached it the same way
you know I don't think Jack Nicklaus was
trying to be friends with anybody I
don't think Joe Montana was trying to be
friends with anybody I don't think a lot
of I don't think Muhammad Ali or Mike
Tyson were trying to be friends with
anybody I think they were going out
there on a mission and if there was
someone in their way they had to crush
him
question let me follow up so you said
Peyton Manning to me Peyton Manning is a
competitor it's like Michael Clyde
Michael Barkley Michael you know it's
like a magic fine but you know it was
like no you know the whole game in the
Olympics whatever game it was where
Michael and Magic what do you call Magic
and bird team up to play that video
that's about four minutes and 30 seconds
and you see it says listen I'm the guy
there's a new Chief in town right and it
was like and like listen Larry says
magic relax we're not at this guy's
level he's better than us right I'm not
talking about competition I'm talking
about who disrespected you because
Isaiah disrespected Michael yeah did
anybody disrespect you disrespect you
that you said it's done
I would say there were I can't think of
any competitors off the top of my head
coaches like I like the guys that would
like you know
and I remember a few instances like if
you guys remember in Dominican Sue of
course okay
and he ended up being a teammate thank
God because
ndamukin was one of the biggest fastest
most explosive athletes the league has
ever seen and the Dolphins signed him to
like a 20 million dollar a year contract
highest paid defender in history and
they were in a division so we see him
twice a year and he had a reputation
that you know he was played to the echo
of the whistle
and uh
I would always try to butter the D
lineman up because I didn't want them
like trying to hit me any harder than
they already were trying to hit me like
they get paid a lot more the more they
kick my ass which that's good incentive
for them so every opportunity I could
get I would try to like you're a great
player man like stay out of my backfield
you know like man like damn you really
hit me hard on that one you know
so in Dominican one time we were playing
in Miami and he had been in the
backfield like a couple plays in the
game and I can feel it because I let go
of the ball and then this heavy disarm
would come in and just boom and I'm not
that big I mean he's and when he hits
you it's like different than everyone
else hitting you and I never wanted to
show him that like God damn that hurt
so he got me a couple times early so I
was like the second Drive of the game
and we were driving the ball and I let I
one two three four five I dropped and I
threw the ball and just as I threw it
boom he hit me again and I'm like how
did he get here that quick
so I slapped them on the butt
and I go dude stand up our
backfield today and he looked at me goes
I'm not your friend
and I was like I respect that I respect
that
I never said another word to him
and he became my teammate a few years
later and I you know I love being his
teammate but look he didn't give that
you know I'm won this or won that or had
this or that and there were a lot of
guys that were you know a lot of guys
would come up to me and they'd be like
hey man it's an honor to be on the field
with you and I was like oh thanks man I
appreciate it in my mind I'm thinking
they're done
foreign
[Music]